Où j'ai foutu mes lunettes ?
il y a deux ans j'ai fait une video sur facebook
Rien à voir mais aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de Facebook.
J'ai décidé de faire une petite mise à jour
Parce que Facebook a bien changé depuis.
Maintenant on peut dire j'aime à tout ce qu'on veut
Ça existait pas avant et ça entraînait des pratiques assez bizarres.
Vous savez, les gens qui laissent un statut, qui aiment leurs propres statuts
qui commentent ce commentaire
et qui aiment ce commentaire.
Vous en avez déjà vu des gens comme ça
A quoi ça sert, je n'sais pas
Peut être qu'ils sont amnésiques?
"C'était trop bien la soirée hier!"
Oh ! Un statut ! 'j'aime'
Oh ! Un statut !
"c'est clair t'as raison !"
Oh ! Un commentaire !
'j'aime'
Oh !
Autre truc mystérieux sur Facebook
Les gens qui mettent leurs métiers dans leurs noms
Genre... "Kévin Boulet Photographe"
C'est très souvent des photographes d'ailleurs
Faudra qu'on m'explique l'utilité un jour.
Bientôt ce sera quoi?
"Jean-Baptise Pignouf Agent de maintenance des unités de production"
- Les unités de productions , c'est ma passion !
Sans parler des mecs qui mettent "officiel" dans leurs noms
Ça veut dire quoi ça.. ? Ça veut dire qu'il y a des gens qui sont "officiel" ?
Et d'autres qui sont pas "officiel" ?
Ou alors ils ont un clone qui se fait passer pour eux?
Je n'sais pas-
"Bonjour, Kevin Boulet, enchanté"
"Ça va ?"
" C'EST MOI KEVIN BOULET OFFICIEL, IMPOSTEUR."
"mince"
"Il m'a découvert"
Il y a un autre truc qui me perturbe sur Facebook
C'est les gens qui change plusieurs fois de photos de profils par semaine
Pas pour mettre une nouvelle photo, non
Mais juste pour changer
Ils mettent celle d'avant
Puis, celle d'après
Puis, celle d'avant avant
comme çà, pour changer
J'ai juste envie de poser une question aux gens qui font ça
POURQUOI ?
Ah, si ! C'est parce que enf.......
Non.. non non non non
Ah ! Ou alors ils ...
Non, non non, c'est...
je vois pas ce qui est logique là dedans.
Bon, le truc qui est bien !
C'est que aujourd'hui, presque tout le monde est sur Facebook !
Et ça c'est très pratique
Dans le monde du travail par exemple
- Cyprien , il faut que tu donnes le dossier à Julien Pichon
- Oui ! Julien Pichon...
- Oui, bien sur ! Julien Pichon ! Bien sûr , ça fait quand même 10 ans que j'suis dans l'entreprise
Je sais qui c'est
Je connais son prénom, bien sur
ça peut même te sauver un petit peu la vie
- Hey Cyprien, Anaïs Bouffi de la compta qui veut boire un verre avec toi ce soir
- Anaïs Bouffi ?
- Non, non non Je suis malade ce soir, désolé
- Je... je oui... je me sens pas bien je...
- Je pensais que c'était un homme...
- Je lui disait"Bonjour monsieur" le matin..
Bon y a pas que des bons côtés à ce que tout le monde soit sur Facebook
Ma mère est sur Facebook
Pire !
Ma grand-mère est sur Facebook
Pire du pire !
Ma grand'mère commente mes statuts
Là j'ai dit non !
Là c'est pas possible
Je peux pas laisser passer çà.
J'ai pris le problème à la base
- Mamie !Qu'est ce qui t'arrive là ? T'arrête ça tout de suite!
- Ça te plairait que je vienne commenter pendant qu'on change ta couche ?
- Beh, c'est pareil voilà !
- Tu arrêtes !
- Sinon je viens à la maison de retraite
- Et je te débranche
- Ah mais je m’en fous !
N'hésitez pas à partager ma vidéo sur Facebook et à rejoindre ma page
Et allez sur Cyprien.fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos
- IMPOSTEUR !
merde !